- Thank you very much.
- You're here in person this time.
- I'm here in person this time.
- I know, I like it.
- That's wonderful.
- I will say though,
I was very jealous of your trip
that you were taking all
the pictures I loved.
That was like my favorite Zoom.
Like that board that you
showed us all the pictures,
it was so cool.
- It was fun, I like to travel.
I like to get out in the world when I can,
when I'm not in production.
- You do like to travel.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna wait later in the interview,
but I heard that you
did even more traveling-
- Oh man.
- after you wrapped the last production.
You go everywhere.
- I did. I went everywhere.
God, where do I start?
I went to Portland to
go surprise my sister
for her birthday.
- Oh I know Oregon, that's beautiful.
- Then I flew to Indianapolis
to go wave the green flag at The Indy 500.
- Oh, I've done Indy 500. That's fun.
- It's fun.
- Yeah, yeah.
- One of my buddies, Connor
Daly's a racing driver
- Oh wow.
and he was like, "Do
you want to come out?"
- And I'm like, "Yeah, cool, great.
I'm not working so let's do it"
- Yeah.
- God, I was everywhere.
I was at Fort Bragg doing some work
- Oh, that's cool.
- with special forces teams there.
I went to Switzerland
to go visit a friend,
went to Vancouver to visit another friend.
I took two weeks in my camper
- Wow.
- around on the national parks,
in like Yosemite and Utah.
- Are you always by yourself?
- No.
- Like, do you ever get lost?
- There's a few U turns.
(laughs)
There's always a couple
U turns that happen
within a trip or whatnot.
- Yeah.
- But I like to wander.
I just like to wander around and sometimes
I'm with friends and
sometimes I'm by myself.
But if I'm just kinda
seeing something new-
- Yeah.
- I'm seeing something new,
then I think, you know,
that's the way to go.
- I mean, that's beautiful.
- Oh Yeah.
- Where are you there?
- That is in Switzerland.
- I love Switzerland.
- That is, yeah, so that's
the real Matterhorn.
I mean, of course growing
up in Orange County,
California at Disneyland.
- You did arrive, yes.
- Yeah. You have the Matterhorn
and there's the fake one.
That's the real one.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- I feel like you need a traveling show
called "This is Me."
"(laughs)
- Something like that.
It's the play of the plan of "This is Us."
- Maybe, maybe.
- I'm just saying, you love traveling
and people don't generally get to go see
all that kind of stuff and it's awesome.
- I think if anything,
hopefully me being out in the world
inspires somebody else to say,
"Oh, I wanna go there. I wanna do this.
- Yeah.
- I wanna, you know,
spend time with my family.
I wanna spend some time with myself.
Just kind of get out in
the world and see it."
- It's so good. It's so good for you.
You're like a walking therapy session.
It's great.
(laughs)
And congrats, I want to say, on your star
on the walk of fame.
- Thank you.
- That's really huge.
- Yeah, it's-
- Is that a huge thing for you?
Like that you dreamed
of since you were a kid?
- I mean, I think when I was younger,
I would think about it.
- Yeah.
- And you know, you think about,
"Hey, I want to win an academy award"
and then you get older and you're like,
"No, no, no, that's
fine. Let me just work.
- Yeah.(laughs)
- I mean do some good works in people.
- Yeah.
- And then I realized, you know,
26 years had gone by and career.
And I was like, "Oh wow.
I've been here for a while."
And they presented me with a star,
- It's so cool.
- and you know, it's just,
it's there, it's there now.
- Absolutely, with all the other names.
You walk down there and you're like,
"Oh my gosh, you're in great company."
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- Yeah. A lot of great
people that have them.
And again, I just, I hope it inspires
the next generation of like young artists
and kids and all that to like go out
and do what they want to do.
- Absolutely. We're lucky.
I just said that the other day
on the couch with somebody.
I was like, "We're so lucky."
They were like saying, "Oh,
you get to do what you love."
I was like, "I know we're so blessed.
There's so many people
that love to do what we do.
And we're like the few
that actually got to."
It's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But, so you started by acting
and running tech for your
high school production.
I started in high school,
like singing and stuff like that.
Was that fun to do the tech stuff?
- It was a blast.
I mean, I think it was
a good learning lesson
to, you know, not just be on
stage and in front of people,
but it was like, "Hey, how's
the entirety production happen?
- Yeah.
- So, I mean, when I was a kid,
I had a truck in high school.
And so my high school drama
teacher, Mariana Herrero,
she would be like,
"Hey, you're in charge of
going to Hollywood to pick."
"Cause I grew up in Orange County-
- Oh and you're the guy with the truck.
- I'm the guy with the ruck,
so I'd go pick up the
lights, pick up sets,
pick up lumber, pick up all this stuff
and build sets and hang
lights and sew costumes.
And I kind of continued that
through college too, so.
- I think that's amazing,
'cause you're well-rounded.
And also I think that sometimes people
don't respect everybody's job on set,
because you don't know what it's like
and it might seem easy to you.
I think that that's really
well-rounded of you,
because you're on set and you know
that kind of what everyone's doing.
And you've been in there a little bit.
I think that's important.
- You understand but at the
same time it's like, why,
like we should all just
respect each other's jobs
to begin with.
- Totally, but it's a different thing.
It's like, have you
ever gone out to dinner
with somebody who's never waited tables?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah and you're like, "Okay."
- And they're not looking
the waiter in the eye.
Like, "Oh yeah, I'll take this, whatever."
- Yeah.
And it's like, just stop,
look them in the eye,
say please and thank you.
- And there's other tables.
It's not just you that
came in to eat tonight.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's so fun to do that.
'Cause I was a waitress.
- So was I. I waited tables too.
Yeah and it's like,
I feel like every like actor, musician
has waited tables.
- Yeah. You have to, you have to have had,
because it's a nighttime job.
So you got daytime to do your stuff.
- Exactly and you can change your hours.
- Change your hours, yeah.
You're always like swapping
shifts and whatnot.
- You get it.
- I totally get it.
- But wait, I also heard that
you're learning Japanese.
So one, like why?
like that's so, it's such a random thing
to want to learn.
- I kind of needed to do
something different with my brain.
Cause like, you know, you
settle into what we do
and like great.
I learn my lines, I show
up I'm Mo, I'm an actor.
Point the camera wherever.
Great, I'm directing,
I'm putting projects together,
working with writers.
Great I'm producing.
I needed to do something else with my head
just to keep active, to keep learning,
to kinda keep growing.
And I was like-
- Breaks up the monotony.
- It does. It absolutely does.
But then this is, you know,
a few years ago I haven't
been up to date on it as much,
but like I started
learning Russian, Spanish,
and Japanese at the same time.
- What?
- Realized it was too ambitious
with my work schedule on "This is Us."
So I just backed off on Japanese.
And now I haven't been in class like
with my teacher in a while,
but like it's floating
around in there somewhere.
- Yeah, that's why I love my kids.
And so I went to a school where there,
you could learn Spanish. That was it.
That was your option basically.
And it's cool, cause now
they have all these options
and it's so good when
you're a kid to learn.
- Oh yeah.
- Like, you know, 'cause when
you're older, it's harder.
- It's hard, yeah, when
you're in your forties yeah.
'Cause I have like every language
from Rosetta Stone in my house.
(laughs)
'Cause I'm like, yeah,
I'm gonna do it this year.
And then I'm, I know a
bit of Spanish, that's it.
And French.
- I've done Rosetta Stone,
I've done all those sayings.
- Oh, Duolingo that owl
is so disappointed in me.
(laughs)
- Yeah, totally.
- I'm like, "Look owl, I'm a
momma too with a lot of jobs."
- Yeah, totally.
- But anyway, I want to say,
do you have like a
favorite phrase in Japanese
that you've learned?
- You know there's, what I loved
about the Japanese language is,
you know, it's not just
word represents this,
but they'll have a word
that would represent
kind of an experience.
- Oh.
- Like there's this one word
it's, (foreign language),
which is the way that light,
specifically I think the sun,
travels through a tree and
makes a shadow on the ground.
- That's won-
- But it's like,
It's a whole expanded experience with it
besides just being a word
that you can use to describe something.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's beautiful.
- I don't really have a lot of opportunity
to talk about ( foreign language),
but like that's a really nice word.
- But it's cool that
it exists. I love that.
And like different
languages that they're like,
you don't have a word
for it, but it's this.
And I'm like, "That's beautiful.
Why don't we get a word for it?"
We're such a confusing
language in general.
- Yeah.
- Like we couldn't do that as well.
So everybody is sad that "This
is Us" is coming to an end.
So are you feeling kind
of bittersweet about it?
Like it's a great cast,
but are you excited
about doing new things?
- I mean, you know, look,
I'll be honest for me.
I mean, I don't really work with anybody,
but Mandy 'cause I'm, you know,
deceased in the present day.
- Oh, that's true, that's true.
- I never worked with the kids.
- But you see every-one, right?
- No, no.
- Oh my God.
- I see them when we're doing press.
- Oh.
- So the thing is like,
they'll be on set like wherever we are.
And like they'll just
kind of group together
and inside joke inside joke
and I'm lost, dead dad.
I've no idea what's going on.
- I'm lost, dead dad.(laughs)
(claps hands)
- Well, like for me,
for me it's like, yes,
it is a little bittersweet
to like leave the group,
but for me it's like, it's the crew.
It's always the crew.
I mean you spend day
after day with, you know,
the people that you're with all the time,
you see them, you walk past them,
you know their kids' names,
you know everything about them.
- Yeah.
- And then it's just gone and done.
- You know, move on.
- It is true though.
Like I still see the crew
from like 20 years ago
when I won American idol.
I still know the crew when I run
into them like awards stuff.
It's so crazy 'cause we've
all grown up together
for like 20 years.
And those are the people that you see
and you'll still see on
different productions.
- Yup, absolutely.
- Yeah. That is true.
Well, someone told me that
you have a set photographer
who's very passionate about
getting the best angle,
which first of all, God bless you, sir.
Angles are important.
- Yes, they are.
- But I want to see that,
'cause let's see some photographer Ron.
I feel like he took y'all.
He took pictures of y'all.
- So yeah.
So this is Ron.
- And then y'all started
taking pictures of him.
- so this is Ron Basstore.
How it all started was, there was a scene
where I'm standing in front
of one of my children's desks
and I'm looking at something on the desk.
And I have James over here with his camera
and I have Coy over here with his camera
and the only place for
Ron to get a decent photo
was to wedge himself behind the desk
and shoot up at me.
And I'm like, "Ron, you realize
you were in my eye line."
I'm looking right at this,
this book, this frame.
And he's like, "Well I
need to get the shot."
- Oh, my God.
- And I was like, "Okay man."
So then I took some photos of him
and it became-
- A joke.
- a joke and a gag where
whenever Ron would be in
just a funny position,
I would take a photo.
Then I started an Instagram account.
(laughs)
Then the entire crew
started contributing to it.
So I mean, I would take photos,
but then, you know, somebody
else would take a photo
just and they would send them to me,
but , "Oh my God, you should've seen
where Ron was today.
He's on the kitchen counter."
"Oh my God, you should've seen
where Ron was the other day."
"Like he's outside under
a ladder under, yeah."
- [Kelly] I love it,
he's sneaking in there.
That's Coy, that's Ron. Yeah.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] You're pointing.
- [Milo] Well, that's it.
And that's the thing, like
he always dresses in black
to blend in with a dark
set, a dark dark stage,
unless we're filming at a pharmacy,
then he's wearing all
white 'cause a pharmacy.
- [Kelly] Oh, oh God. (laughs)
- [Milo] I mean, so this one
right here, Logan Scheuer,
it's a big scene.
I think season three,
where Kevin breaks his knee
and his football days are over
and I've got this massive speech
where I'm talking to Kevin, telling him,
like, he's gonna find his true calling.
And I see Ron just creeping
out from behind the-
(Kelly laughs)
- While you're like trying to be like so-
- And I'm like, "Ron,
you gotta leave man."
- You're killing my vibe.
- You really are, yeah.
- Well that's another
thing, I'm never doing that.
I'm usually just like
(loud guffaw)
singing what I like.
- [Milo] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] What? What? That's creepy.
- [Milo] So, that was reflections.
So again, you know, Ron
would dress in dark clothes
'cause he never wants to reflect
or something in a surface.
- Oh, my God.
- So this was, he couldn't
reflect in wherever we were
so he just shrouded himself entirely.
I got so many photos that day.
That one was I think, taken by Creaky,
our sound board operator.
Everybody though that day sent me a photo
of Ron in a black Cape, just.
- If Ron were really funny
he would've had someone
else just sit there
and then just walk up with
another camera. (laughs)
Like who's the guy under the sheet?
- I mean, I have photos
of just his camera sitting on tables,
like on the Instagram account too.
we're just like, "Ron, like
literally where are you?"
- It's on auto.(laughs)
He's like, " I was busy."
- I mean there we go. And
here's your gentlemen.
- There's Weiss! Get it Weiss! Yes!
(claps hands)
- Weiss has actually been.
That's what I'm saying.
Weiss has been around me for, God,
I don't know, 15?
I don't know how many years
we been working together.
But on tour, I don't even
notice Weiss is there.
Like there've been times,
(laughs)
things have happened and I
have no idea Weiss is there
and I'm like, "Well, anyway."
Well, one of your other jobs
is narrating audio books.
So this is my question. Like, I have two.
One, do you do different voices for them?
And then also, do you enjoy audiobooks?
I try and read, but I
like something tangible.
- I like reading. I like reading too.
I particularly like thumbing through
an actual page of a book,
but I will read on an iPad or a Kindle
or something just because it's
just easier when traveling.
- You get a headache. Okay.
- I do.
- But sometimes the
audio people are boring.
- Well, sometimes you just
don't like their voice.
- That's what I'm saying.
- I've been on really
long drives and I'm like,
"Oh God, I didn't have
time to read this book
and I'm so excited."
- Yeah.
- And I'm here for hours
and then I put it onto mic,
"Wait, no, oh God, I'm not gonna.
And I turn it off and then
I would never read the book.
Then I'd hate the book.
Then I hate the author and all of this.
And you're like-
- Yeah, 'cause it's a whole thing.
No, I literally, this
is the best thing ever.
It was like supposed to be this
like inspiring, self motivating book.
And it was like, it was like,
the author wanted to do it
and I was like, "You should
have had someone else
read your book for you,
because it's literally the opposite
of inspiring and motivating."
Your voice, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah totally.
- So do you do that
though? You do audio books?
- Oh, I have. I've done
a bunch of audio books,
a bunch of podcasts and things like that.
- Are you interesting? Would I like them?
- I think so. Well-
- Okay.
- So, there was a series of books I did
called The dangerous days of Daniel X.
This is a couple years ago now,
but they're for, you know, young kids,
- I like the later stuff.
- they're for kids about like
eight to 12, 13 years old.
- Okay.
- It's about this alien
hunter who is also an alien
and he goes to other worlds and planets
in different times and dimensions.
So there's all kinds of
wild characters in there.
- I'm 39 and I'm gonna enjoy that. Go.
(laughs)
- It's amazing.
But I would have to track
every book that I would do,
the characters that I would voice
and make them different in like,
you know, his best friend who's a girl
sounds a little different than him.
And he's got a different voice than his,
you know, crummy brother-in-law.
- Oh, I like that, you go in-
- Oh yeah, I go super detail.
- Okay, okay.
If we gave you a line
to read, do you think
that you could show us the
difference in the characters?
- I hope so.
- Okay. Don't fail.
- I mean, yeah.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- No pressure, Milo.
Okay, let's put a line in prompter.
Let's do the first as oh,
the romantic male lead.
- Around noon the next
day things took a turn
when Jane let her true intentions be known
and one thing became abundantly clear.
I had to act now.
- That was, yeah.
(apllause)
- Romantic lead.
I'm thinking flowy
hair, like shake it out.
- Yeah, you don't even have
to wear Vera's lenses. Nice.
Oh, that was nice. For later.
(laughs)
Okay, I want you to be a villain.
Do it as a villain.
- Do it as a villain.
- Okay. What's a villain?
- Around noon the next
day things took a turn
when Jane let her true
intentions be known.
One thing became abundantly clear,
I had to act now.
- Oh my God.
You could be, you should
play a serial killer.
(applause)
- I did. I did on Gotham.
- You did? Oh my God, I missed that.
- It's Okay, a lot of people did.
- I saw Hero's, I saw Gilberger,
I saw all of them but that one.
- Dammit, I was like the one I didn't.